this is the video
that i invite you my viewers my
subscribers
to leave comments on comments for
forthcoming 10 short videos on
whatever it's going to be when i bundle
them together
the video series that i started using
vu footage and now i'm going to continue
using just regular flip cam footage so
if my saying that totally confused you
here's the back story
about what would it be three four years
ago i was involved with this this social
network called vu
and it used your computer's webcam to
record
two-minute or shorter messages which
were responses
to other v users questions or comments
which they would leave on your
your uh your page so
vu ended up going belly up they they
weren't really sustainable
there's a whole long story there that i
don't want to go into um
and long story short they they sent me
uh
a whole bunch of short videos that were
my responses
so i thought what can i do with this
stuff and i thought well i could
you know i could bundle them together by
by topic
and i decided on 10 because it's a nice
you know even number
and i started bundling together so there
were some on
philosophy in general and some on
politics and some on religion and some
on critical thinking
which are the ones i finished up with
some on more personal topics
and there was a lot of good positive
response
the religion ones tended to get a bit
more mixed response but religion videos
always do
and people said i
i'd like you to continue doing that so
that's
that's what i one of the things i want
to do and i think maybe i'll do
one of these a month or maybe two a
month
and i want to stick to the same general
idea of having 10
short videos on this particular topic
not just
all over the map so
here's what you do if you want me to
consider including your contribution
in one of those one of those videos um
just put a comment and the comment what
i mean is a google plus comment you know
the comment can be a comment it can be a
question i don't want anything that's
very long
i want things that are that are one to
two lines
one to two sentences because if i'm
going to respond to it in two minutes i
don't need you know
a whole paragraph i already talk at
great length already it's a real
challenge for me to try to get something
in under two minutes this video is
you know for example is going to be way
over two minutes
so um if you want if you're interested
in this sort of thing
if you'd like to get uh your your two
cents in
leave a comment and what i'm going to do
once i start getting enough of these
comments is
i will uh i'll shoot responses to them
then i'll put a sort of mark with a
comment of my own as a response saying
hey i responded to this one in video
number 12 or video number 13 or video
number 14.
i don't want viewers to necessarily
respond to each other's comments on this
video
by you know saying a great idea or dumb
idea or anything like that
because i don't want too much clutter in
the screen but i would say
feel free to vote up or vote down each
other's comments i think that would be a
great idea
if you have an idea of your own that you
want to
to put in there don't piggyback it on
somebody else's comments
put it in as your own thread so
those are some of the you know maybe
guidelines or basic rules or something
like that
there's a few other things that i do
want to say about this this whole
process
um so i don't want
i don't want a lot of comments that are
hey i like your channel or stuff like
that because i'm not going to respond to
those i already do respond to that sort
of thing
when it pops up on my channel or um
in other in other places you know thanks
for this video i respond on those
so i don't want that sort of thing and i
don't want questions about when are you
going to do this kind of video when are
you going to do that kind of video
what i want are more of the sort of
stuff that was showing up in those 10
short videos it could be
what do you think about this you know
i've heard that you mentioned that you
were involved in this what was that like
and i'll try to give a very very short
thumbnail discussion of it
you know i've had a lot of varied
experiences
i'm willing to give my opinions on quite
a few things provided that people
understand that they're my opinions
and you know i'm a philosopher i'm not a
theologian
i'm not a scientist you know there's
there's some things in which i can i can
say something
interesting but i'm not to be understood
as being some sort of
uh expert um
comments should be like i said pretty
short and and uh
i don't want them to be very adversarial
because i want this to be sort of a
collaborative process
if you don't like somebody else's idea i
don't want you to weigh in and say
hey dummy that's a bad idea or terrible
idea or something like that
if i think it's a bad idea and i don't
want to engage with it i'll just erase
the comment
right so you don't have to do that i i
want the comments and questions to be
fairly focused i want them to be about
things that are
not super super general like what is
your view about being a human being you
know that that's a little bit too
too general for me the sort of thing
that would be worthwhile answering not
only for you as an individual
but for other people it could be
interesting to hear
hear what what i have to say on that um
don't make the comments very competitive
or abusive or tendentious
or even snarky because i'm just going to
delete those
i already already get you know my fair
share of those like every other
uh video content producer and those just
go right into the
the trash can so
those are the basic guidelines um
the door is pretty wide open the one
thing i think that you do want to keep
in mind
is i am going to be assembling these
into 10
short videos on this topic or that topic
so if you pick something that's like
totally off the wall and nobody else
would ever have any interest in it
it's going to be kind of hard bundling
that into
into something else but otherwise you
know
just if you want to give the comments
keep them coming
this is the video this is the spot to do
that
and i will we'll use this as sort of a
dynamic
kind of substitute for a website because
you'll get to see
when i actually respond to the comments
through through videos
and
we'll just do this as an experiment and
see how it goes
so once again i invite you to
to leave comments which should be you
know either
comments per se you know declarative
sentences
or questions that you'd like me to to
address or answer
and i will uh do my best with them